[Music]
here's a positive note when it comes to
body image things for women are getting
better yes the media still pressures us
to be thin
eating disorders still plague us there
are still products and services trying
to sell us what is a beachbody according
to them but we call those things out
with a confidence and a clarity like
never before social media is now full of
women proudly claiming their body's fat
bits saggy boobs big thighs new mum
bellies and all the other things that
make us glorious but for the last two
weeks I have been filming abroad with an
entirely male crew and let me tell you
it was a shocker
these guys were constantly lamenting
their appearance weighing themselves at
every opportunity sucking in their
stomachs in every photo shunning
desserts and comparing carb count and
protein powder regimes they spoke
mournfully of the pressure to achieve
the perfect body it's about time we
talked about where the male body image
is in crisis okay
I'm out what I don't agree with is the
part where you say that you know we're
across the body confidence issue with
women because we're we're nowhere close
I just thought let's improve I know I
know but I don't that were anywhere
close to it even being improved um you
know there's lots of stuff that will say
it's the single biggest cause of mental
health problems every image in young
women and young men I do agree with the
fact that the public dialogue around
this is female centric that's for sure
you know and because we're men aren't
supposed to be worrying about their
bodies what you just said I think about
the guys you were with to me I've never
come across a bunch of guys out of my
life and I'm not entirely sure what I
said if I did but but but but I think
young men have always been crippled with
anxieties about their body we've just
knocked over you know boys growing up
they're crippled with they lose hair
early they get acne probably more than
women do they worry about weight as well
but I think that I think what's happened
that was and this problem is gonna
remain as long as society is obsessed
with gorgeousness and it is shows like
love islands you have to be perfect not
God have you film you have to have a
six-pack and apps and all the rest of it
and I think as long as the world of
advertising as long as the world of
social media TV movies promotes gorgeous
people I don't know how that's gonna
change halfway it should but I don't
know how it's gonna I think the point
difference is is that it's accepted that
women are gonna dye their hair they're
going to have beyond you know talk about
diets constantly dire eyelashes all the
rest of it but you know caper Lee's
written today in the Daily Mail about
having had her second facelift in her
50s and she's completely open about it
but there isn't the same openness and
forgiveness accorded to them to men and
they're constantly laughed at for you
know code they're comb-overs or they're
two peas or they're man buds or they're
paunches and that is I think underlines
a lot of the anxiety that men feel
because if they do take steps to sort of
cosmetically alter their appearance
though they're considered unmanly back
to the Donald Trump that disgust with
with it would on a very serious note
traditionally come on look at Arnold
Schwarzenegger bodybuilding I mean it's
gone people young men have always wanted
to some of them be it you know strong
bodybuilders but the big difference I
think the big difference has taken place
is this rise of mobile phones
and selfies I mean in the olden you had
a camera how many people turned a camera
around took a picture of themselves now
the biggest thing on the Internet of
photographs trillions of photographs a
year are taken on the internet and this
narcissistic culture sort of self
promoting this is what's driving a lot
of it and and the and the other side was
not just wanting to look good in
bodybuilding terms it's also the
negative side of it I guess what I am
saying is I'm not in any way it's a
belittle the struggles that women still
have I agree with you I'm not saying
we've won that at all I just feel that
there is now a countervailing pressure
that there is a kind of backlash against
that women are very vocal calling out
things that pressure them whereas I'm
not seeing the same conversation I mean
are you gonna go public about your
second facelift Nick I haven't had a
face if you think these are my real
teeth you would be very very much
I want to know who you were filming with
Village People a British regular guys
that are these fans from from young like
20s to middle age I love them surprised
and I'm not I don't usually you know I
don't usually when you travel in a film
crew you'll together for breakfast lunch
and dinner kind of 16 hours a day every
day for two weeks you really get to know
people and I just got this insight into
what's going on in the psyche of this
cross-section of British men you know it
really may be that this mantra time to
Gendo that looks don't matter there's an
amazing actress in prison yeah we do or
what say there's much more important
things character personality is much
more important young people aren't
buying that because that's not their
experience their experiences that looks
very much ado matter looks matter to get
your job to get you on television to get
you Fame to get you money and as long as
it as long as that is being pushed in
society there's if there's a fantastic
she's an actress and TV presenter called
Jameela Jamil do you know her she's yeah
okay so she speaks a lot about body
confidence of women and she just says
you know there's an epidemic of low
self-esteem and she said you know for
every moment they're thinking about how
good-looking they they are they should
be thinking about fun fun whatever but
jameelah is the most glorious looking
woman ever she's beautiful so so the
message doesn't come across you have
this beautiful woman saying looks don't
say she suffered from anorexia for years
as a teenager was and and experienced I
gave it real mental health challenges
didn't and that pressure and I get what
she's doing is coming from the very best
place but young people are looking at
her and she's she's devastatingly
good-looking there are there are lots of
women who are who talk about being fat
and owning that as a term on social
media there's saggy boobs matter is now
a campaign big noses matter there are
lots of women who are trying to create
positive movements that break no telling
it your beauty even if it's not what the
media people now the way they present
themselves on social media you don't see
the real person it's all photoshopped
and people are trying to portray
themselves not the real real person and
I think this is pressure you notice men
feeling under pressure either of you
have you experienced I met two songs and
I think that they are much more
where of their own sort of appearance
than my brothers were when we were out
one nobody ever took photographs of us
and if they did they they were burnt and
this this scrutiny self scrutiny and
also societal scrutiny via the visual
culture has led to a doubling in eating
disorders recorded by boys going into
hospital over the last eight years
almost a doubling so what that tells us
is that these pressures are now being
felt if not equally by both sexes a lot
by boys as well as girls and me young
men as brothers lost a lot of weight
Rachel I noticed a selfie Boris you
mentioned love island calve let's just
hear from someone who appeared on love
island and also social influencer Adam
Collard both male and female struggle
with it just as much and everyone needs
a little bit of support but I think
there's a lot more out there for women
and women seem a back each other up more
there is a lot of like plus-size models
and stuff like that and who are their
support and achai though they're helping
each other and there's a lot more out
there but there's not really for young
males all I know is when I grow up I
want to look like Tarrant and I'd be
quite I'd be quite happy with that well
I'm not saying celebrity status doesn't
have its perks but the constant selfies
as we've just been hearing autograph
requests and attention from fans can
sometimes wear slightly thin so spare a
thought for Pope Francis he wasn't too
keen on people getting close to his
bling this week the pontiff was spotted
ripping his hand away from worshippers
who wanted to kiss the papal ring as a
sign of respect for the office a close
aide explained sometimes he likes it
sometimes he does not just to let you
know this footage does contain flash
photography take a look
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's Teresa made Frannie take my
advice that's why Pope Francis you're a
mover and shaker of the week someone
would say to those peers don't kiss his
hand there should be an official say
they don't like it I used to get shamed
by my Jesuit headmaster when I was
school in India for taking comic books
to school came by my headmaster he's a
very kind gesture he's a soft jazz whip
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can join in the debate just search
for the pledge on Facebook or Twitter
see you next time
[Music]